long before the marvel cinematic
universe conquered the world sam raimi
ushered in the golden age of superhero
movies courtesy of his spider-man
trilogy but will we ever see his
spider-man 4 keep watching for raymie's
answer thanks to sam raimi's
blockbusters about peter parker and his
alter ego marvel adaptation stopped
being a laughingstock following years of
ill-fated movies like howard the duck
are you nuts
the director along with star toby
maguire helped turn spidey into a bona
fide live-action star it's been smooth
sailing for superheroes at the movies
ever since naturally fans of spandex
crusaders were excited when raymie
agreed to helm doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness however now that
raymie has finally joined the mcu many
people would love to see him return to
the spider-man saga and oversee the
friendly neighborhood arachnid's next
mcu outing unfortunately raymie doesn't
envision himself cheating on his own
spider-man franchise with the current
iteration while spider-man 3 didn't
exactly blow people's minds many fans
would love to see raymie have another
crack at a spidey flick in the near
future especially after learning that he
had plans for another sequel back in the
day however the director wouldn't direct
the next tom holland lead flick if he
was offered the chance as he doesn't
want to upset his favorite spidey actor
in a recent interview with the los
angeles times raymie praised spider-man
no way home for opening up the
multiverse and bringing some of his old
friends into the fold he also had kind
words to say about the direction in
which the mcu has taken spidey with
holland in the star and role even if his
personal loyalties lie elsewhere raymie
said i love spider-man and i love tom
holland in the role but if i made a
spider-man movie it would probably have
to be with toby or he'd break my neck of
course raymie might consider returning
to the spider-man franchise if marvel
agreed to let him make a new movie with
maguire he previously told fandango i
don't know if marvel would be interested
in that right now i don't know what
their thoughts are about that i haven't
really pursued that but it sounds
beautiful even if it wasn't a spider-man
movie i'd love to work with toby again
in a different role
sam raimi had plans for a fourth
spider-man movie back in the 2000s but
that was a long time ago the hollywood
machine has continued to churn out hit
movies since then and raymie has moved
on with his life these days he doesn't
even think about spider-man 4 very often
during a recent conversation with screen
rants raymie revealed that spider-man 4
isn't at the top of his project wish
list at the moment on top of that he
doesn't even know if marvel's head
honchos are interested in resurrecting
his iteration of the franchise raymie
told the outlet i currently don't have
any plans to make spider-man 4 and
they're so successful with the new
spider-man series that i don't know if
that's gonna happen or not i haven't
pursued that still stranger things have
happened in hollywood prior to
spider-man no way home no one expected
maguire holland and andrew garfield to
play their respective spider-man in the
same movie theoretically raymie could
make spider-man 4 and it would make
sense within the context of the mcu so
never say never and if you need more
reassurances you'll be pleased to know
that a notable marvel employee wants to
see this dream become a reality grant
curtis the marvel producer whose credits
include moon knight as well as sam
raimi's original trilogy of spider-man
films believes that raymie's franchise
still has life left in it during an
interview with gizmodo from earlier this
year the producer revealed that raymie
and company came up with plenty of
material for more movies years ago so
they aren't short of ideas should
spider-man 4 ever materialize curtis
said the spider-man movies we made were
an incredible opportunity career-wise as
a fan i loved the narratives that were
generated from those three movies there
were other stories within those movies
that did not get told i hope sunday as
any spider-man fan would tell you that
all of those stories come out and that
narrative continues
curtis might only have been sharing his
personal opinion but it's good to know
that some influential people have
spider-man 4 in their thoughts it
remains to be seen if ramy gets to
finish telling the stories that he
envisioned all those years ago however
he does reportedly want to make a batman
movie and that's arguably even more
exciting than spider-man 4
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mcu are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]